>> Tucker: AND JUDGING BY
ELECTION RESULTS ACROSS COUNTRY,
THIS COULD BE A VERY TOUGH FALL
FOR IT REPUBLICANS.
THIS YEAR IT COULD BE WORSE THAN
USUAL FOR A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
REASONS, BUT ONE OF THOSE
REASONS MAY BE AT THE
REPUBLICANS ARE RUNNING ON
ENTIRELY THE WRONG ISSUES.
YOUR AVERAGE REPUBLICAN
OFFICEHOLDERS SEEMS TO BELIEVE
THAT MOST AMERICANS LOVE MASS
IMMIGRATION.
THEY SAY THAT ALL THE TIME.
IT TURNS OUT, IT'S NOT TRUE.
BIG REPUBLICAN DONORS LOVE NEST
IMMIGRATION, AND SO TO
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS, IT
INCREASES THE SIZE OF THEIR
PARTY.
CONSIDER THE NEW CVS U GOD OF
POLE.
FAR MORE IMMIGRATION THINKS IT'S
MAKING IMMIGRATION WORSE AND NOT
BETTER.
45% OF AFRICAN-AMERICAN SAY
IMMIGRATION IS HURTING THEM AND
ONLY 17% SAY HE IS HELPING.
HOW ABOUT HISPANICS, WHERE ARE
THEY ON THIS?
REPUBLICAN CONSULTANTS TELL YOU
AND THEY TELL THEIR CANDIDATES
NEVER TO SAY A NEGATIVE WORD
ABOUT IMMIGRATION FOR FEAR OF
ALIENATING HISPANIC VOTERS.
TURNS OUT THAT'S IDIOTIC AND
PATRONIZING AND ACTUALLY 44% OF
HISPANIC VOTERS SAY IMMIGRATION
IS HURTING THEIR COMMUNITIES.
JUST 28% SAY HE IS IMPROVING
THINGS.
THE NUMBERS COULD NOT BE MORE
CLEAR.
IMMIGRATION IS A POWERFUL ISSUE
FOR AMERICANS OF ALL KINDS, AND
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT REPUBLICANS
CAN WIN ON IF ONLY THEY WERE
BRAVE ENOUGH TO LISTEN TO
VOTERS.
BUT, THEY ARE NOT.
AFTER A YEAR AND A HALF OF TOTAL
CONTROL OF CONGRESS, NO WALL IS
BEING BUILT, CITIES ARE BEING
WELL FUNDED, CHAIN MIGRATION IS
ALIVE AND WELL.
NOTHING IS HAPPENING.
NOW THAT THE MEDIA IS TELLING
YOU IT'S IMMORAL TO SEPARATE
IMMIGRANT PARENTS WITH THEIR
CHILDREN, LOTS OF REPUBLICANS
BELIEVE THAT.
BUT WAIT AMERICANS WHO GET
ARRESTED ARE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR CHILDREN.
AMERICAN CITIZEN SHOULD BE
TREATED MORE HARSHLY THAN
ILLEGAL ALIENS?
HOW IS THAT?
HERE'S THE ATTORNEY GENERAL ON
THE SUBJECT.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE BELIEVE EVERY PERSON WHO
ENTERS THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
LIKE THAT SHOULD BE PROSECUTED
AND YOU CAN'T GIVE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
BRINGING CHILDREN WITH THEM.
IF PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO BE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CHILDREN,
THEY SHOULD NOT BRING THEM WITH
THEM.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU HEAR JEFF
SESSIONS CRITICIZE A LOT FOR A
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT THINGS BUT
WHEN IT COMES RIGHT DOWN TO IT
ON THIS ISSUE, HE IS THE ONLY
PERSON IN WASHINGTON WERE STILL
ARGUING THAT BORDERS AND LAWS
MATTER.
TO BE THE REST OF THIS PARTY
WILL WAKE UP AND REALIZE THEY
DO.
LOU DOBBS JOINS US TONIGHT.
YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THIS ISSUE
MORE DEEPLY THAN ALMOST ANYBODY
I KNOW.
DOES THAT SURPRISE YOU THAT NO
ONE HAS PAUSE TO ASK, WAIT A
SECOND, IF IT'S WRONG FOR
ILLEGAL ALIENS TO BE SEPARATED
FROM THE KIDS WHEN THEY COMMIT A
CRIME, WHY IS IT NOT WRONG FOR
AMERICAN CITIZENS TO BE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR KIDS?
>> THERE ARE PREDICTIVE GROUPS
IN THE UNITED STATES BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
THEY ARE A PREFERRED GROUP.
IT IS SO BECAUSE THE
ESTABLISHMENT, THE BUSINESS
ROUNDTABLE, CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
U.S. MULTINATIONALS, THEY WANT
CHEAPER LABOR, THEY WANT OPEN
BORDERS AND THEY WANT TO QUOTE
UNQUOTE HARMONIZE THOSE BORDERS.
YOU DON'T HEAR MUCH ABOUT THE
NORTH AMERICAN UNION ANYMORE,
BUT UNDER GEORGE BUSH AND
THROUGH MOST OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THE
NORTH AMERICAN UNION, THAT IS,
BRINGING CANADA AND MEXICO
TOGETHER WITH THE UNITED STATES,
WAS THEIR ULTIMATE GOAL.
THEY JUST HAD TO BACK OFF
BECAUSE OF THE NUMBERS THAT YOU
JUST SHOWED IN THAT POLL.
THE REALITY IS, AMERICANS
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS HAPPENING.
WHATEVER THE RACE, WHATEVER THE,
WHATEVER THE SOCIOECONOMIC
DICING YOU WANT TO DO WITH THE
NUMBERS, AMERICANS KNOW WHEN
THEY ARE BEING LIED TO AND THEY
CAN FEEL THE REALITY.
THE REALITY IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE BORDERS BECAUSE WE IN THE
LAST MONTH JUST RETURNED TO THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDERS.
>> Tucker: IT SO INTERESTING
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS,
DEMOCRATS WILL TELL YOU, THE
MEDIA TELLS YOU AND A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS TELL YOU THAT PEOPLE
DON'T LIKE IMMIGRATION BECAUSE
THEY ARE RACIST, THEY ARE
BIGOTS.
LESS THAN 20% OF
AFRICAN-AMERICAN SAY IMMIGRATION
HAS MADE THEIR COMMUNITIES
BETTER.
THEY ARE NOT FORWARDED.
HISPANIC AMERICANS, SAME THING.
SO, IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT
BIGOTRY, ACTUALLY.
BECAUSE THIS CUTS ACROSS RACES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND OF COURSE THE ENTIRE LEFT
WING AND ESTABLISHMENT ARGUMENT
COLLAPSES IF PEOPLE LOOK AT THE
REALITY.
THE REALITY IS, AND ALL OF THOSE
ETHNOCENTRIC INTEREST GROUPS AND
ACTIVIST GROUPS ARE BASICALLY
SPEWING PROPAGANDA.
THEY HAVE -- IT'S ALL BEEN
PICKED UP BY THE NATIONAL
LEFT-WING MEDIA SUPPORTED BY THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND CORPORATE
AMERICA.
OBVIOUSLY, TO THE DETRIMENT OF
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN,
PARTICULARLY AT THE LOWEST
PAYING LEVELS IN THE LOWEST
SKILL LEVELS, LOWEST EDUCATION
LEVELS IN THIS COUNTRY.
BECAUSE OF PEOPLE CROSSING THAT
BORDER AS THE PRESIDENT IS MADE
CLEAR THROUGHOUT AND IT'S NOT
COMING ACROSS ON THE BASIS OF
MARRIAGE.
THEY ARE COMING ACROSS ON THE
BASIS OF MEXICAN GOVERNMENT
POLICY WHICH INSIST THAT THEY BE
TRANSFERRED TO THE UNITED STATES
TO BE THE LEAST ADVANTAGED AMONG
SOCIETY.
>> I REMEMBER VIVIDLY WHEN WE
WORKED AT ANOTHER NETWORK AND
PEOPLE LAUGHED AT YOU AND IT
TURNED OUT, YOU ARE COMPLETELY
RIGHT.
THAT MUST FRUSTRATE YOU.
>> WHILE THEY STILL LAUGH A
LITTLE BIT I HOPE BECAUSE WE
SHOULD HAVE A SENSE OF HUMOR
ABOUT THE REALITY THAT IS
AMERICAN POLITICS.
WE JUST ELECTED A PRESIDENT IN
2016 THAT WAS TALKING ABOUT EACH
OF THESE ISSUES AND THE IDIOT
ESTABLISHMENTS ARE TELLING THE
REPUBLIC AND PARTY THEY SHOULD
RUN ON TAX CUTS INSTEAD OF ON
TRAY TO COME ON JOBS, ON MARKETS
THAT ARE IMPROVING, AND, THE